are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
folks we are back with episode number
what is it today 160 one six with dr
peter pry we brought him back we had him
on what was it two weeks three weeks ago
you were on two or three weeks ago yeah
three weeks three weeks ago we had you
on and by the time we were done i said i
want you back because
uh i don't think two hours was enough
for some of you guys that didn't get a
chance to watch the first one he
is one of the world's leading experts in
weapons of mass destruction and emp's
executive director of task force on
national homeland security a
congressional advisory board dedicated
to achieving protection of the united
states from
electromagnetic pulse cyber attacks mass
destruction terrorism and other threats
critical civilian infrastructure on an
accelerated basis last time when we
spoke
we talked a lot about uh the motive for
russia versus ukraine we talked about
you know
how you know what can an emp really do
nuclear bombs what are they capable of
doing uh how bad can it get how paranoid
we are we learned the word suspicious if
you remember last time there was a new
word we added to the vocabulary we
learned in cia you don't need to have
good eyesight to become a cia agent
that's kind of what you whispered to us
the fact that you wanted to go in the
military but your eyesight didn't allow
you we learned a lot of different things
from the last time till today things are
changing very quickly right now
what has changed with russia and ukraine
that you are i'm sure you're following
the story very closely what's changed in
the last three weeks
well the uh
as the situation gets worse
uh for for the russians uh
you know i'm afraid it may move us
closer and closer to the edge you know
of that nuclear precipice
uh
putin has getting
even though uh russia is an
authoritarian state
uh you know he has lots of different
advisors from the military from the
intelligence services
of the services the military services
compete with each other
and uh
and and they're probably making
recommendations for
a wide variety of options nuclear and
non-nuclear options
uh for putin to execute
and uh
uh
the longer the conventional war appears
to go against russia
the more likely it becomes that one of
these options will be executed
and
there's a broad and deep consensus
among the american strategic community
even among people who have been very
anti-nuclear for example anti-nuclear
activists who work for the middlebury
institute of international relations in
monterey who are you know have been
pretty notorious for their anti-nuclear
views are saying that well you know the
russians may well uh execute uh some
kind of a limited nuclear attack in
ukraine and they published an article uh
within the past couple of weeks talking
about what those nuclear options are you
know one of them is an atomic
demonstration a nuclear demonstration of
anovia islam assembly of the russian
test site up in the arctic ocean where
they would
light a nuclear weapon off in the
atmosphere which hasn't been done since
the early 1960s as a demonstration that
russia is serious about going nuclear
another option and i was very pleased to
see that they they mentioned this was an
emp attack on ukraine
even the monterey institute anti-nuclear
left is taking the emp threat
seriously that they would do an emp
attack on ukraine which would fry the
electronics across ukraine
you know disable the ukrainian army and
that would create conditions where the
russian army could now win
you know because the ukrainian army
armed forces would be disabled ed would
as would the whole country of ukraine
because their electric grid would be
down
all the electronics all the
communications would be down and a third
option
they described
uh was a actual uh
limited use of one or a few tactical
nuclear weapons and the ukrainian army
to use blast or thermal effects you know
to blow holes in the army so their guys
could pour through
and uh and uh destroy basically the
ukrainian forces on the ground by means
of of tactical
limited tactical nuclear strikes and i
agree that those are options that are no
doubt being proposed to putin but i
think there are other options that are
are
even more serious that are being
proposed to him
you know i think the
one of the options was one of the
scenarios the emp commission had
proposed before there was ukraine war
and that is to do an emp attack detonate
a super emp weapon
70 kilometers high over nato
headquarters in brussels
and this would have the effect of
blacking out
european nato
from ireland all the way to ukraine
and uh that would immediately stop
uh any uh any arms you know going into
ukraine from from the nato member
countries would paralyze nato so that we
would not be able to intervene in the
nato in the uh in the ukrainian war and
it would send a signal to the united
states that we had better stay out of it
or would be next
and there are there's a faction you know
of i think a very influential and
powerful faction within russia that
would advocate that because there are
new thinkers uh who believe
and and they have codified this in their
military doctrine uh that this kind of
an attack an emp combined with cyber
warfare
is the most revolutionary form of
warfare that has ever just existed in
history yeah you know because you can at
the speed of light basically take down
your adversary paralyze him and win a
war
almost literally at the speed of light
and it would and the initial attack
would kill very few people you know so
it's a clean surgical way of paralyzing
your enemy enemies and winning
and uh they have the capability uh to do
that so why not do it and uh they have
been writing in military doctrinal
assessments you know for uh
almost two decades about about doing
that so that's a faction that would be
saying you know let listen to us
vladimir you know let's do an emp attack
that's not just on ukraine but on nato
europe because it's going to accomplish
who's saying this this is coming from uh
this would be coming from the russian
general staff and those people who are
who specialize in in electro electronic
and uh the cyber warriors now let me ask
the cyber when it comes down to super mp
when we were kids
uh i don't know if you fooled around
with m80s and you'd blow up an m80 and
like oh [ __ ] that's pretty cool and you
would try to put the m80 in this thing
you would try to put it underground ac
would blow up anything would happen yeah
you would do all this stuff with m80s
and then every once in a while one of
the guys would bring something that was
bigger than an m80 and you thought the
reaction to the m80 was going to be like
an median you know what an m80 does
right right and you put the other one
that was a bigger thing more powerful
dynamiting like holy [ __ ] we were not
ready for this right and some people
could get hurt how do we even test super
emps like i know north korea uh has
apparently you said north korea has
tested super emps but
aren't super emp's almost one of those
things yeah i see that article right
there north korea tested a super emp
weapon that could potentially wipe out
nearly the entire united u.s population
so here's my question how the hell do
you know
how do you know that could wipe out the
entire us population and how do you not
know that maybe it's
either worse or weaker than what you
think this is like one of those things
that's tough to test you know you can
test it in one region that can affect a
lot of different people so how do we
really know the
true
negative
impact of emp how bad it could be how
big it could be or how small it could be
oh i think we have lots of uh of
evidence
you know during the early 1960s for
example
when we did the
test over johnson island in fact we
didn't even know about the emp
phenomenology we just knew that the
russians knew about something that some
phenomena was happening because they
were conducting a series of tests over
kazakhstan
they were detonating nuclear weapons
varying yield including very small ones
and very big ones in outer space over
over their own territory over kazakhstan
which was an inhabited part of russia
kazakhstan's an enormous area about the
size of france
and uh and so we decided and they were
breaking the uh there had been a an
agreement to not do
atmospheric testing anymore and they
were breaking the agreement this thing
was considered so important for them to
do that and so we did a test over
johnston island and lit off a nuclear
weapon in outer space and it basically
knocked out the lights in hawaii
caused automobiles to fail knocked out
radio transmission stations and things
like and hawaii was 1500 kilometers away
it was just on the very edge of the
field where the field is weakest
and so we could see that that had uh you
know
profound effects
and we have built emp simulators
after we stopped atmospheric nuclear
testing and exo atmosphere because this
is actually being tested in outer space
when when you detonate the weapon it's
not in the atmosphere but we have these
uh
emp simulators so we can put all kinds
of electronics the commission on which i
served is the last
or uh really concerted effort where we
did uh the broadest and most in-depth
analysis of the effects of emp on modern
electronic systems by putting all kinds
of things into into simulators and
frying them
you know because we know what the emp
fields will look like you can calculate
it from the gamma ray output of a
nuclear warhead it's called the compton
effect you know the gamma rays will will
come out of the bomb they'll knock
electrons off of atoms and the high
atmosphere the electrons will spin at
the speed of light following the earth's
magnetic field to the horizon and that's
what makes the emp and it basically
creates this this pulse
that's like a super energetic radar wave
or radio wave
you know for a non for a normal nuclear
weapon that's 50 000 volts per meter
that means for every meter of of
dimension of the target it gets 50 000
volts injected into it so uh you know
the the the wires on this
thing here probably are a half a meter
so this thing would get 25 000 volts
injected into it at the speed of light
i'm sure it's not designed to survive
that you know uh
if you had an automobile that was uh you
know typical automobile might be four
four meters long so that's four times 50
000 so 200 000 volts
injected into the car's electronics at
the speed of light a super emp weapon
can generate
twice that or more than twice that and
so you're talking about extraordinarily
powerful fields
our electronic civilization you're i'm
answering your question in my
long-winded way about how do we know
well we know because our electronic
civilization is pretty much
almost everything is designed to operate
on 120 volts or less
you know that personal that computer
sitting in front of you is probably
operates on on 25 volts you know it's uh
it steps the power down from the but the
outlets
in this in this area put out 120 volts
okay so things that are designed to
operate on 120 volts almost certainly
are not going to survive when you inject
50 000 100 000 200 000 volts at the
speed of light into them and we know
they don't survive because we have
simulated that for many decades you know
both the department of defense and the
last the commission on which i served we
weren't just a paper commission you know
we were about actually testing modern
electronics to see where the electronics
vulnerable we knew they would be
vulnerable but one of the questions we
wanted to know is are they getting more
vulnerable and and they are because
microchip technology you know which is
responsible for the great prosperity and
efficiency of our modern electronic
civilization every decade
it gets 10 times faster operates on 10
times lower voltages okay but that also
makes them every decade about 10 times
more vulnerable so we're going in the
direction of greater and greater
vulnerability and then and then we have
other things that we can look at what
happens when the lights go out for
example in hurricanes or tornadoes or
ice storms what happens to society we
have lots of data to show that
24 hours after lights go out
about when people miss their third meal
you know the glue that holds society
together starts coming unglued and uh
and uh you know when society just starts
very quickly disintegrating so we do
have a lot of data it's not just
theoretical we have uh
you know we can test this stuff through
simulators we have seen it tested and
nuclear
detonations of the past and we have
real world experience every year from
hurricanes hurricane sandy hurricane
katrina you go back and you look at what
happens to society and this is just a
small scale thing when you have these
blackouts that affect regions and
they're only temporary
imagine uh if you had you know a
phenomena that would black out all of
north america for a year
that's how we uh you know we tried hard
to think how do you keep 330 million
people alive
for a year with no electricity which
means
no water
no food the food supply we only have
enough food in this country to feed 330
million people for 30 days in the big
regional food warehouses and it will
immediately begin to spoil when the
temperature control systems and
refrigerators and stuff stop receiving
electricity you can't get the food
to the grocery stores you know because
the trucks and transport vehicles would
be paralyzed uh you know there's only
enough food in a grocery store at normal
consumption rates to feed the local
population for two or three days how do
you keep 330 million people alive for a
year with no food no water
you know no organized government you
can't i mean we we tried very hard to
come up with ways of doing it including
mobilizing the army to air drop food
supplies into the cities you know meals
ready to eat we have you know a billion
meals ready it's not enough
and uh it's not practical that's why our
recommendation was you know we can't
afford to take an emp hit and expect to
survive we've got to harden our critical
infrastructures protect the electorate
you have kids of yes you have grandkids
i do okay so
are you
concerned or suspicious that a potential
super emp could one day be
you know
used by an enemy of ours against us in
america
that was the option next option i'm
thinking the putin is getting advice on
from
some factions because among his cyber
warriors there are others who are going
to say we should go bigger than just
attacking european nato but a basic
fundamental question do you think
are you suspicious that one day that an
attack like that with a super emp could
be used against american that would
impact negatively your your kids your
grandkids
under these circumstances in this
ukrainian war i'm i'm very fearful that
it could happen tomorrow okay so how are
you personally prepared for it you know
well we have a a little farm that's uh
all set up you know we're prepared to
live without electricity uh you know and
you own a little farm that you're ready
for yes okay got it and what kind of
food do you have that in case that were
to happen
you know you're ready how many months of
supply of food you have because some
people may be listening to this they're
also sitting there saying
you know some who maybe have the ability
to do so you don't buy life insurance
policy because you're thinking you're
going to die tomorrow you've done you
buy because if you do you want your wife
your husband okay so
so
what kind of food do you have how much
supply of food you have how prepared are
you very prepared you know while we've
got the ability to to survive for years
for years yes uh you know the location
of my farm is uh
well i'm not gonna talk about where it's
located okay but it's just a very remote
uh remote place it's close enough to
washington so that i can go there when i
have to uh you know but it's far enough
away it's one of the least populous
counties in virginia so that if we were
to exhaust our canned food and we've got
plenty of that that's what i would
recommend you know stockpiling high
caloric canned food you know beans
chocolate peanuts you know uh
spaghetti uh all kinds of canned food
because that way rodents can't get at it
and canned food will basically last
forever i mean even though they have
expiration dates on the canned food you
know that's just for quality of
appearances in terms of the
wholesomeness of the food
because it's in a vacuum it'll basically
last forever we we recovered uh
there was an arctic expedition
uh that was lost
uh in the early 1800s
and nobody knew what had happened to
them you know for uh you know for many
years uh but we eventually found them uh
you know more than a century after the
expedition had failed they were one of
the first expeditions that were bringing
canned food with with them and the and
the food was still good you know uh
years after uh years after that water is
critical you know
you know uh
uh it's best to actually have a natural
well you know so that you're not
dependent upon
uh you know
the larger water infrastructure
uh
uh you you can make homemade filters
quite easily with a garbage can and
blankets and charcoal that would
that would uh that would
refine water purify pure purify water
but uh uh it's a good excuse for having
a swimming pool you know twenty thousand
gallon swimming pool you know and it can
be one of those above ground pools that
are very inexpensive i mean this is not
the kind of thing you need to be a
millionaire to be able to afford
everybody should be able to you know be
survivable that'll not only could you
support your family with that but you
could probably provide have a water
supply that would support a whole
community do all the members of your
family have something like this yes
and this was something that you
encouraged them to do or they've read
enough of your books and material that
they said all right i'm convinced i got
to move on with this
well both either way that's uh yeah
that's uh you know both because they've
read my stuff and been around been
around me
uh
uh
are you a doomsday prepper
i hear that terminology all the time i
see those commercials but this is what
that sounds like is that would you
categorize yourself as that
i would categorize myself as uh
as uh
uh as the remnant
of uh the great generation
you know be that's one of the things uh
you know i find it particularly annoying
you know modern culture
condemns preparedness now
by mocking it and calling people
doomsday preppers okay overly paranoid
you know my my mother and father but
that's what they call themselves though
well i don't call myself that uh you
know i call myself an american i call
myself a person who
has the character profile that this
country was originally founded
by the founders
people who believe in rugged
individualism and self-sufficiency and
are jealous of their freedom
uh and don't believe in in in trusting
the government to take care of all of
our needs which is where we have become
now uh those who call me a doomsday
prepper i would say those who don't
prepare are sheep
uh you know the kind of mentality that
the founders
uh
well our this country wasn't designed
for sheep it was designed for eagles it
was designed for people who believed in
freedom and believed in self-sufficiency
and not taking handouts you know my my
father's generation uh the generation
that lived through the great depression
and survived world war ii they had never
heard of emp
uh all of those people all virtually all
of them
would be doomsday preppers because they
didn't believe in trusting the
government to take care of them they had
seen government fail and war and peace
that seen it fail in the great
depression that seen it fail with the
outbreak of world war ii
they knew
my father and my uncle joe for example
who fought in world war ii you know
again against the nazis my father was a
sergeant my uncle joe had been a private
they knew that world war ii was not won
by franklin roosevelt and general george
patton world war ii was won by
tough guys like them you know who went
up against nazi tanks that were better
than ours
better armed and better led
uh
germans and defeated them that was their
guts and blood that won world war ii and
so you know uh they were not uh you know
uh
uh willing to trust in government they'd
seen government fail in peace during the
great depression and in war and they're
the ones that got us through world war
ii and that attitude persisted
afterwards that's why in the 1950s so
many americans were digging bomb
shelters you know we laugh at that today
and seem to mock it today but they were
really concerned the government screw up
again and would have a nuclear war and
they wanted to survive and make sure
their family would survive
you know we lived on a quarter acre and
uh you know we had
orchards
uh you know
apple trees a garden my mother was
constantly canning food might they had
never heard of emp but they were
concerned that there would be some
disaster maybe an atomic was that more
common back then than today do you think
that was more of a common oh absolutely
etiquette
it was a common value of all americans
beginning with the founding of this
country because those virtues that we're
talking about here the self-sufficiency
the rugged individualism the pride it
was a point of pride that you wanted to
be able to take care of your own family
and not depend on a neighbor and
certainly not depend on a church or a
government to take care of you you
wanted to be able to take care of your
neighbors yourself
i have a slight and pushback if if i may
sure
there's something you talk about is
something that's great in theory but
that's great in practice
with you a hundred percent on rugged
individualism taking care of yourself
taking care of your family being
self-sufficient limited government a
thousand percent on the same page
however i also am a personal finance
expert i also know that 80 of americans
are living paycheck to paycheck i
understand that people are you know have
budgets i understand that inflation is
at eight percent it's going all-time
high
gas is expensive um cost of living is
expensive so if i'm
all right all right dr price i'm with
you i'm ready to go get a farm in
virginia or a place in the everglades or
something
how do you
take that theory and put it into
practice if you're making 50 grand a
year or you're making a hundred grand a
year or even if you're a
multi-millionaire what percentage of
your budget should you be putting
towards getting a
a bunker or something like that because
it's great in theory amazing of course
everyone should have a bunker but who's
actually doing it and that's what i'm
grappling with right now about three
percent of the population is actually
doing it right now and that's a shame
you know because of what it reflects
this passing of
what we would call the pioneer values
the values that we're talking about here
are what made america great and free in
the first place and most americans up
until my father's generation the great
generation
had those values and were prepared and
they weren't making a hundred thousand a
year my father was making less than
fifty thousand a year but they were
prepared for anything and uh you know
ever heard of a victory garden i mean
that was very common during world war
two and uh and people made them on their
on their own
uh i remember in my uncle joe he owned a
bar down in utica new york and he had a
tiny little backyard i mean it wasn't
you know it was the size of a living
room what is a victory garden it's a
it's a it's a it's a cultivated
wikipedia it's a war garden or food
gardens for defense
or vegetable where vegetables vegetables
fruit and herb guns are planted at
private residences and public parks
united states uk canada interesting yeah
in world war ii almost everybody had a
victory garden and they and they would
grow their own food everybody anybody
that's in a time where people were
living in the suburbs you had all this
land now majority of americans are in
new york city in l.a in chicago downtown
miami my uncle joe there's living in
places like this my uncle joe was living
in the middle of utica new york okay and
as i was explaining to you uh the
the backyard behind his bar was maybe
the size of a living room where's utica
new york though york new york's in
central upstate new york okay so what
happens if i lived in new york city you
know
well if you live in new york city you do
you can you might want to think about uh
do you have friends who live in the
country here's what i would if i can
jump in here here's what i
what percentage of america do you think
needs to own a life insurance policy i
mean anyone with kids or a business okay
only 54 do 46 don't right yeah some of
them can't do it some of them cannot do
it right okay uh what percentage of rich
people here live on the water
there's people that are waterfront
property mostly a lot of these guys are
your friends okay they got houses in
miami whatever you know
beachfront
intercoastal whatever maybe okay great
uh those guys are probably not gonna
have a nuclear you know
bomb shelter with victory gardens in the
backyard where they're living at but
when a hurricane happens what do they do
what happens when hurricane happens
they've got uh well either they leave
town okay what happened i've never been
part of a hurricane inside but the other
day the weather was pretty crazy what
happened but when a hurricane happens
what do most people do in florida they
put up their shutters and they just
buckle down or some of them drive up
right they get out of dodge okay they
get out of dodge so this isn't for a
hundred percent of people
the way i'm processing this
it's not for 100 of people and to be
honest with you let's just say you don't
have a lot of money as a family
what i would do it in some like this to
prepare for it is i would have the
family
collectively decide to get one look
your your
religion your faith is what you're
you're you grew up judaism right i'm a
christian right i don't know what you're
uh
what you grew up with yourself
i grew up around a lot of mormons
i was in an insurance company lots of
guys there were more lds lds yeah
and
one of the things that was very
fascinating about the church of
mormonism okay
is they prepare their people a lot i
don't know how it is with judaism
but there's nobody more suspicious than
paranoid than jews okay so then just
know that but but then but then but how
far do they take that because at mormons
that i went with many of the people that
were leaders stake presidents all this
other stuff
they had in their homes they were ready
that was one of the things that was very
consistent this is in utah no not in
utah it wasn't in lodi california it was
in you know l.a it was basements they
were fully prepared for that in case i'm
in atlanta like and i'm talking like
in cummings georgia and not like you
know they were ready for something like
that and these are not people these are
people that are like hey
if something happens we're ready for it
this doesn't mean you go be to you know
a place that's very exotic and all this
other stuff it's just something you
build by the way
can you pull up with what i just sent
you check this out uh peter dr price i
don't know if you've seen this or not so
these are 11 luxury doomsday bunkers
around the world right i mean this is
pretty weird a little bit flamboyant but
one of them was very interesting keep
going lower
keep going lower these different designs
okay so this one's a little bit too much
fine this one's in europe
fully okay uh uh
yeah that looks like that one movie with
uh what was that one movie with that one
uh comedian years ago
from encino man what's the guy's name
paulie sure
biodome it looks like the bio don't keep
going just bust out survival condo watch
this one watch this one here watch this
one here that's insane that's insane to
me it's going down it's not going up
going so down so depending 15 floors so
the penthouse there would be the bottom
floor think about that age negative 15.
keep going down keep going down keep
going down trident lake not familiar
with this area but there you go that's
another spot las vegas underground
shelter doomsday bunkers look at this
one they got a pool there they got a
little house keep going down the
aristocrat
they got game rooms keep going lower the
safe house keep going lower keep going
lower keep going lower okay that one
that one apparently goes up so those
those gates come up this almost looks
like from the movie purge by the way or
i am legend or i am legend yes yes
closes that's right keep going keep
going a little bit more to see a couple
other ideas
okay this is pretty interesting this is
bunk bed so that's like a military model
uh keep going lower keep going lower fix
the point
lower lower lower lower interesting
shelters at the bottom this is in west
virginia
global seat wow that's good
where's that at where's that at
global seat vault to doomsday bunkers
huh that's very interesting go a little
lower in norway that makes sense we got
kaido that would he would be prepared
for something like that so dr price to
go back to
uh uh
somebody's listened to this and you said
three percent okay
to be in the top three percent you have
to make
250 a year
200 a year that's what the three percent
makes because one percent's around 450
500
20 in six figures three percent you're
around 250 a year to be able to afford
something like this right
what what are some places
uh i following up with your uh meeting
that we had i called a few friends
okay who are you know to see what they
would say
one of the guys i called on who i'm
gonna have on the podcast if he feels
comfortable about it he'll talk about it
he said yeah absolutely i got i got to
spot myself and i'm ready for it he says
do you know your favorite podcast you've
done all year you know which one it is
he's asking i said now who is it he says
it's dr peter pry you know how many
people i've shared that with i said i
don't know and by the way this is a guy
that's a very well-known guy the people
know who this guy is
he says that's a podcast everybody
should watch because most people are not
ready for it i said okay now what
to to you know put it in context he's in
his late 60s early 70s so he's living in
a different phase of his life
but he said he's got a place in south
carolina
what are some of the common places that
you're aware that people are buying
you know
nuclear shelters or you know doomsday
shelters whatever they call them is it
specific or it's general it can be
anywhere i want to push back please on
this idea that the preppers were talking
about that the three percent that we're
talking about are the three percent of
the wealthiest americans that's not true
the three percent who are preppers uh
you know include are probably mostly
people of the middle class and even
lower income
brackets you know that do that i suspect
there are more of them because i think
there's more common sense among the
middle class and working class people
than there is among the millionaires and
the billionaires
you know i actually don't disagree with
you i don't see them being a little more
paranoid than someone who's super
successful common sense and it doesn't
cause well also people who live in rural
areas and uh you know there are a lot of
americans who supplement their income by
hunting okay to get protein because meat
is so expensive these are people who are
still from that
they still have those pioneer virtues
okay that we were talking about that
used to be the virtues and the values
that all americans used to have up until
about a generation ago when we started
changing and becoming more trusting of
the government and expecting government
to take care of us there are a lot of
americans you know from working class
and middle class backgrounds that still
have the old-fashioned virtues that they
inherited from their parents generation
as did i you know my father taught us to
hunt and fish he had never heard of emp
you know but he did that because he had
fed his family through the great
depression by hunting woodchucks and
fishing and so that was part of
preparedness it's not just recreation
uh similarly now anybody
you know
even people on a modest income can do
something to prepare you know stockpile
food stockpile you know it doesn't cost
a lot of money to stockpile
you know canned
beans are very inexpensive you know
all kinds of foods that are out there
that are very inexpensive the more you
stockpile the better off you are have a
medicine kit and know how to use it
exercise some common sense if you live
in the middle of new york city you know
might you might want to think about
you know uh where are there still places
that have the old 1950s civil defense
signs you know what is the what building
has the deepest basement you know so so
that if i was concerned about a fallout
and i don't want to stress that you know
we're so terrified about radioactive
fallout actually it's probably not going
to be a lot of radioactive fallout and
that's probably not as big a threat as
uh as people are worried about because
the cities are probably not going to be
attacked you know the adversary
would make a counterforce attack
maybe we should be talking a little
about the basics of nuclear strategy to
educate people about what they're going
to uh what they're going to face
uh you know basically
uh
the
worst case
one of the worst case scenarios and one
of the and this is a scenario i think
that is being advocated to putin right
now as well we didn't really talk about
all the factions that are out there but
uh uh you know another faction are
people who still believe in uh
field martial vladimir
sukholovski's uh
approach that was written in the 1960s
and that and that any new any war any uh
you know any
use of nuclear weapons is going to
escalate to an all-out war so you might
as well launch a preemptive first strike
against all your adversaries you know
and take out the nuclear forces of
britain and france and the united states
to win the nuclear war right off the bat
and go big if you're going to go nuclear
you go big
you know this is the suckalovsky theory
and uh and i'm sure there are still
people advocating that that's why
they've built up a first strike
capability with their strategic rocket
forces and that's one of the reasons
putin's been talking about the satan 2
recently which is their new first strike
weapon okay they've still got the satan
one which is very effective and you know
it could destroy probably well over 95
percent of our icbm silos but a russian
counterforce attack
there are two kinds of attacks we think
of in nuclear strategy one is a counter
force attack where you're trying to
disarm your adversary by destroying his
nuclear forces and then there's the
counter value attack where you go after
cities and industrial areas and the
population centers
almost
certainly
you know they would uh if they went big
and and the suckalovsky
faction uh wins out
they would be they would they would uh
execute the counter force attack
uh you know they don't want to attack
cities initially in that first wave
because you want to hold the cities
hostage to force your adversary to
surrender
and so what do they need to attack our
are to execute a counter force attack
they can do it with 500 warheads this is
the equivalent of 50 satan 1
50
satan 1 icbms
could deliver 500 highly accurate
nuclear weapons that would destroy
the 440 icbm silos and launch control
facilities the three strategic bomber
bases and the two ballistic missile
submarine bases and that would destroy
almost all of our nuclear weapons except
for
those that are on the ballistic missile
submarines at sea
you know on patrol
typically we have a third to a half of
the submarines that see on patrol it's
more like a third these days because the
ohio-class submarine is so old
uh you know and that's about
you know
about 400 weapons that we would have out
there at sea you know that we would have
surviving now what are you going to do
with those 400 weapons go attack empty
icbm silos in russia vacant bomber bases
ballistic missile submarines that are no
longer in port on their side
impervious
deep underground shelters
and then you'll have no nuclear weapons
at all left after you've used up those
and that will leave our cities open and
exposed to attack and we would have
we would have no recourse but to
surrender or see our population
destroyed
you know the logical thing well the
reason we have the ballistic missile
submarines on patrol is they are a
secure reserve they're not supposed to
be used
except to deter the adversary from
attacking our cities
so that attack you see that base
basically
be able to to uh
if you pull that off and destroy our
forces
it would leave them free to commit
aggression against our allies and have
their way with the rest of the world
uh and threaten our adversary cities and
conquer the world that way uh except the
united states would uh you know would be
saving our cities and uh and uh at least
be safe for the time as long as we had
those that handful of submarines on
patrol out there
so that's how the logic of how nuclear
force would work and
because they're trying to limit
collateral damage to the civilian
population the survival of our civilian
population is an important strategic
asset to them
they don't want to maximize casualties
they want to
limit the casualties their objectives
destroy those icbms in their silos which
are all located in very low population
areas by the way the ballistic the
same thing with the uh the air force
bases there's only three of them
and they would do things like
uh
do low altitude bursts when you're using
your nuclear weapon because this is this
maximizes the over pressure the blast
effect which is what destroys an icb
upside or destroys a bomber base but
uh and uh the the blast effect there's
it's called an optimum burst height okay
the higher up you go the bigger that and
more effective that blast wave is and
this happens to be good from in
perspective of limiting collateral
damage to the civilian population
because as long as the fireball doesn't
touch the ground you're not going to get
any or or very little nuclear fallout
radioactivity so the counter force
attack will not generate a lot of
fallout and radioactivity so people
don't have to have
nuclear bunkers or or even worry about
uh you know going into some deep
basement in new york city if you happen
to live in new york city those would
that is a good thing to do it's a good
thing to scout that out i'm not saying
you shouldn't have nuclear bunkers i
mean that's a if you can afford it
that's great but what i am saying is
that for the average person or even
people that don't have a lot of money
there's a lot of things you can do
little inexpensive things that would
significantly increase such
such as such as storing food you know
putting aside maybe one percent of your
budget
how many
how much canned food can you put away
having a water supply having a medicine
kit knowing how to use it
do you have friends who have a place in
the country so that you might be able to
work out a survival plan with them where
you're going to be able to get to them
somehow how big is your shelter that you
have i'm not asking specifics but it's
something that can it fit
15 people or family members or i don't
have an underground ship oh you don't
have an underground shelter okay i used
to in my place in maryland but this is a
new uh
you know so you're a little bit more
optimistic right now than you used to be
uh
i wouldn't say that i'd say i'm i'm i'm
less optimistic but i'm uh
it's not a question of
of of optimism but uh the uh then why
don't you have one you know
well because i think that that's the
last thing you really need you know i'd
rather put the money into
stockpiling food
raising chickens you know uh you know i
don't think radioactive fallout
uh you know but bunkering yourself uh i
think this is based on a myth i just
explained how a counterforce attack
would work no no i i totally get what
you said i i get what you said and you
you you actually
i'm hoping putin doesn't watch his
podcast because your other podcast was
translated into russian and our russian
channel that's got a few hundred
thousand subscribers but uh so
what i'm asking you is the final one
so you in your mind this is how i
process it feel free to push back if you
don't have a shelter at this point of
your life and you are probably wealthier
today that you can afford it versus when
you used to be in maryland today you
could probably get a shelter if you
wanted to
is it because you think it's more likely
for us to have a
super emp attack before a nuclear attack
is that kind of how you i think it's
much more likely that we would have a
super okay that's why cyber attack and
that that faction you know is arguing
for vladimir putin's ear and trying to
get him to listen to them instead of
going to
i got a nuclear war yeah so so okay
so so but but my but the reason i don't
have my shelter anymore has not because
i'm more optimistic today i don't have
my shelter because the obama
administration punished me
for criticizing their national security
policies and canceled my defense
contracts okay so i couldn't afford
my farm in maryland and the and the
state of maryland in 2008 raised the
taxes on people who had farms so high
that the people who had been living
there for 300 years had to sell their
farms is that literally the reason why
you don't have that is the reason if i
if i if i had not uh if i had not had to
give up my farm in maryland i would
definitely still have it today i had a
shelter in that farm that could have
survived a
uh a one megaton attack
attack happening relatively close by
uh you know the house was designed to
survive that and it was a a better set
up but you know i ended up uh like a lot
of people you know uh got coming out of
that so that i uh you know i'm not as
prosperous today as i used to be thanks
to the obama administration
and uh you know and financially i never
came back to that so i'm doing the best
i can
i'm not a rich guy i'm doing the best i
can with what i what i've got i'm very
uh i'm satisfied uh you know with uh
with what i've with what i've done we've
uh
this new
farm where we're setting up uh you know
is actually further away from washington
because i'm less optimistic that
washington isn't going to get nuked you
know than i was before you know i've
moved my family to a what i think is a
safer safer location got it so before
the closer you are to washington safer
you are now you're thinking the further
you are from washington the safer you
are yeah yeah well i never thought that
the closer you were the safer you were i
always thought that the closer you were
to washington the more endangered you
are
you know uh that that's a
uh you know that president biden doesn't
make you feel safe
no no he doesn't nor does uh the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
general miley you know i think we've got
one of the least competent
and most dangerous administrations
where nuclear war is concerned that that
we've ever had
you know they they genuinely believe
that a nuclear war cannot be
won and must never be fought
and uh that's patently untrue
uh but it emboldens them to take risks
that previous more responsible
administrations would not take you know
i think their whole ukraine policy is
based on the fact that there's a lot of
people in the buying administration that
really think oh putin agrees with us
that a nuclear war cannot be fought and
it cannot be won and must never be
fought and therefore we can we can
go as far as we want in ukraine we can
push ukr
putin out of power and and prevail over
russia at a conventional level in
ukraine and we won't have to worry about
a nuclear war because putin isn't crazy
and he understands that a nuclear war
cannot be won and must never be fought
that is false that's a very dangerous
assumption but the people in charge of
us now in charge of our national
security
actually believe that
what did uh the previous administration
under president trump how did you feel
about you said you don't feel very safe
under biden or general milly
under
trump and his his administration did you
feel any different oh yeah i i felt a
lot uh a lot more safe
uh
uh you know if only because of trump's
personality uh you know he was no fool
uh he didn't say things like you know
nuclear war cannot be
won and must never be fought
uh his uh
nonetheless even under president trump
uh okay the president would make certain
claims that weren't true
uh such as what well for example that
america uh that our military has never
been stronger and we're better prepared
now than we ever have been that's not
true because he had been increasing
defense budgets it takes a long time
uh
uh on president trump was doing the
right things i mean he was investing
money in in modernizing our nuclear
triad okay
but under president trump uh uh you know
one would get the impression that we
spent all this defense money that
therefore our triad was stronger and
better
it wasn't you know
all of the
all of the nuclear submarines and
bombers and missiles and all of the
warheads on all of those systems
are 30 40 years old they go back to the
reagan administration and president
trump
didn't change that
you know it's going to take a long time
to modernize the triad
it's and we're not going to get
new systems coming online until a decade
from now into the 2030s okay
now i'm not criticizing president trump
for making those statements i think as
the president
it was important for him to make those
statements because nuclear deterrence in
a lot of ways is based on a big bluff
you know uh you know
by him saying things like that and
asserting that and threatening our
adversaries
uh they didn't know what to make of him
i actually think that his personality
that strong patriotic personality that
potential unpredictability that's what
the word i was about to say yeah you
know unpredictability yeah that's
powerful deterred them okay some some
people might call it um erratic though
well
when you know when you're facing a
situation where the adversary has all
these advantages
you know uh anything that deters them
and makes them pause uh you know is a
good thing including
that erratic behavior if he's
unpredictable aka erratic you know
interchangeable or interchangeable in
some capacity regardless
the enemy doesn't know what to make of
it is that what you're saying the enemy
could
uh you know would have
the enemy would not was not confident i
think under president trump that this
guy might not himself launch a nuclear
first strike if he thought that america
was endangered
one he could easily see president trump
doing anything necessary to defend the
united states including striking first
and that scared them so
so that they
they were
more that's why they didn't invade
ukraine but think about this
opposite of unpredictable
give me another word
no it's not no type in unpredictable
synonym
level-headed
unpredictable what what is so it's a
very simple word just take the u.n out
pretty opposite of unpredictable it's
pretty predictable yeah that's i mean
and i'm not even american i wasn't born
here the opposite of predictable is
unpredictable it's predictable
and when it comes down to
war the last thing you want to be is
what predictable here's what's crazy
isn't it crazy that the guy that the
world thought was going to start world
war 3
the world was at peace and the guy that
thought that was going to bring world
peace is created the world into mayhem
everybody thought biden was going to
bring a lot of peace it's been a [ __ ]
show when it comes down to safety and
everybody thought trump was going to
bring war the only place that was a [ __ ]
show was on twitter okay when when he
was here
to me
um okay so let's if you have a follow-up
i can go with other questions if you
don't have a follow-up form did you have
a follow-up question on that topic or
trump
so then let me continue so i would go to
this with you
um
so you know historically which political
party typically likes war
that's fine which histori which
political party are you saying the
republicans the warhawks typically
asking you what would you say
historically hopefully neither party
likes no or no that's not true though
that's not true historically republican
okay so people will typically say
you know when it when it comes down to
the republican party is like feeding war
like even if you watch the movie vice
the way they build dick cheney and you
know what he did to get all those
contracts okay cool
so iraq all of that yeah now if you go
back if you go back to bush can somebody
say well that was true
that was the case right there was a lot
of war okay well if you go to obama
do we have wars during obama how was
under obamacare isis a war every day we
feared isis right i mean isis was like
that was the media though just like coke
but no no but but but that the media is
on his side that's talking isis that's
his side it's not
99 of the media loved and adored obama
so if the media is talking about it it's
real because obama was president not
because somebody on the opposite side
was president so you can't confuse the
two and you bring to trump
the four years is pretty quiet nothing
really happens palestine and you know
kushner does what he does and then you
have now biden so
this is the question i got for you is
your putin the guy that you're saying
one of his advisors the general hey why
don't we do a super emp on ukraine and
maybe even nato you were talking about
that earlier 40 minutes ago
and
you know but at the same time again
you know let's go into the mind of putin
today
uh biden just gave ukraine 40 billion
dollars it's public you know so we're
gonna support ukraine
and uh
biden's become a friend of ukraine a lot
of people on the media support that
decision they say that was a good move
to be made
uh
nato is defending anybody against russia
almost everybody against russia
how is putin
sitting there saying
these guys don't fear me because if if
you look at that picture between these
two guys you got trump and putin okay
what do both of them have in common both
of them if there's an area they're
competing in
is which man is more unpredictable to
impose fear okay would you agree with
that both of them are in a way
unpredictable right now you want the guy
that's unpredictable
to be on your side the guy that's
unpredictable that's not on your side
you don't like that but if the guy is
unpredictable and he's on your side
you're good with that both of these guys
are unpredictable
how is an unpredictable putin process 40
billion dollars being given to ukraine
and public humiliation and he's sitting
there saying well you know maybe we'll
take a little bit more maybe they're
going to finally figure out that i'm a
good guy and what do you think he's
thinking right now how much more can he
sit there and keep taking all the
support that ukraine is getting rather
than leaving that alone okay before i
answer that question i'd just like to
clarify what i said about president
trump before because i'm a trump admirer
i don't want that being misconstrued you
know we had started off you know
you know because i don't want it
misunderstood that i was criticizing
president trump when i said well he said
that our military was the strongest in
the world
when that was not so okay
it is the case that if you look at our
forces and what was done you know
there's no way that in the four years of
the trump administration we could have
gone we could have modernized our
nuclear forces so so quickly
uh uh you know it wasn't true that we
had the strongest military in the world
our nuclear forces certainly were still
far behind and our military forces were
not prepared yet to fight a can a pure
competitor a conventional level
uh you know but i support president
trump saying those things because he's
the president what is he supposed to say
oh our nuclear forces are
are far inferior to those of russia but
i'm spending money and i hope that in 30
years we can catch up with them that
wouldn't be a prudent thing for a
president to say the president has
always got to say we're the strongest
we're the best we can beat anybody so
you know from a military technical
analytical point of view uh you know uh
those things weren't literally true but
in terms of what presidents are supposed
to do yes you know i'm i'm glad
president trump was saying that he's not
just communicating the american people
all the bad guys in the world are
listening to him and if they had the
sense that oh this guy
is admitting publicly that america is
weak you know you don't want to do that
biden in effect is doing this now uh
when he decides uh you know that uh that
we're going to cancel the sp over the
protests of all of over the pentagon you
know that he's defunded this slick a man
the sea launched cruise missile nuclear
was our only hope to catch up with
russia in terms of our tactical nuclear
weapons and he's also
canceled the b-83 nuclear bomb you know
which is the only weapon that uh it's
the our last megaton class weapon that
had some kind of a chance of driving a
shockwave that could destroy command
bunkers in russia and he canceled that
in the middle of this profound nuclear
crisis over ukraine what kind of signal
is that sending them it tells them that
he's afraid of nuclear weapons or
indifferent to the nuclear balance to
such an extent that even this kind you
know he's he's he's defunding and
canceling some of our best weapons so
having said that how does putin
processing 40 billion dollars sent to
ukraine well uh you know we know how
he's processing it and he's basically
telling his people uh uh that uh that
the war in ukraine uh you know is not
just a war against ukraine but the that
ukraine is a proxy war being waged by
the united states and nato against
russia
and uh and he and he's basically saying
you see i was right to invade ukraine
even though things aren't going well i
was right
because ukraine in effect is a de facto
member of nato and these guys are
planning to use the uh
ukraine to try to destroy russia they're
doing it now uh you know uh there's all
this nonsense that we didn't have to
worry about nato and ukraine is proven
false because they're basically treating
ukraine as a de facto nato member now
they're still afraid enough afraid of us
because of our nuclear capabilities that
they're not willing to directly engage
russian troops uh you know uh there but
we this proves that i was right and that
we have to prevail in ukraine because
this poses an existential threat uh in
effect we're in world war iii right now
a world war iii is being waged against
russia via
via ukraine as a pro a proxy war
and uh the russian people are listening
to this you know putin is far more
popular among the russian people now
than than biden is among the american
people you know he has tremendous
support for prosecuting that that war
and winning it and uh
i think as i as we discussed in the last
program
what is putin going to do
uh
uh
you know we don't the fog of war is so
thick over ukraine you know we don't
really know
you know just how bad is the situation
for russia and for putin
internally we're almost all the
information we're getting is coming from
the ukrainians on the battlefield and
from a biden administration that wants
to make the russians look as bad as
possible you know because biden doesn't
want the narrative to be about
biden throwing away 60 years of u.s
national security credibility on the
international stage when he drew that
line in the sand and told putin do not
invade ukraine and then russian tanks
are rolled right over it you know he
doesn't want the conversation biden
administration doesn't want the
conversation to be about that they
wanted to be about how badly the
russians are doing allegedly doing
maybe in reality doing so badly
uh you know uh in in
in ukraine and and therefore
uh you know the politics are not so bad
for biden
from that from that perspective but go
go to proxy words aren't proxy wars
supposed to be like
people don't know you're doing a proxy
war or else it's not a proxy war if it's
public it's no longer proxy you're
taking sides so
do you understand what i'm saying when i
say so you so let's just say if you ask
you are saying us is doing a proxy we're
using ukraine against russia
u.s israel ukraine
versus when sometimes the they would use
iraq iran they would use these
surrounding countries and
behind closed doors they're supporting
one of the countries but not everybody
knows about it that's the right way to
do proxy not a public proxy war well it
depends how you define a proxy war there
have are proxy wars where a country will
want it be to be done clandestinely uh
so that it will have plausible
deniability uh for example uh iran's
support of the houthis and yemen is
there is a proxy war like that where
they say we're not supporting the
houthis all of this stuff is uh you know
even though they're supplying arms and
uh the north koreans are in there too
helping them with saudi arabia
to scud missiles right against saudi
arabia but that's very well known you're
saying that was supposed to be
clandestine at the time though at the
time well there's still words i feel
like there's a lot of proxy wars that
are out in the open i mean look at
what's going on in gaza israel i mean
palestine iran everyone i mean that's
very well known the vietnam libya
vietnam okay the vietnam war
with the soviet union i think the
intention is what you're saying is to
yeah i keep it on the deal
if you're doing it the way we're doing
it we're not like just supporting
ukraine we're anti-russia
we are anti like we are ukraine yeah but
so is the entire eu
i totally agree but what i'm saying here
is this is not the proper way of doing a
proxy work well just say just say
we we are going to defend these guys
because we're not going to do anything
to work with russia we're not going to
have a conversation with russia to try
to figure out a way to
you know eliminate this war slow down
the war or praise play sinner just to
say listen can we figure out a way to
make this work no we don't want to do
that you know he's the next this and you
saw when biden one time we have to get
rid of them and then he slip up and then
they come back and correct them that was
what three four months ago when he said
that i remember he only says that
because that's talked about behind
closed doors you don't say that and have
a slip up if it's not something that's
being talked about people don't have
slip ups like that so it's no longer
proxy in my opinion i get what you're
saying when the proxy is using somebody
else to go to it it's wide open right
now and putin knows it so if if you're
if you ever thought about negotiating
with putin and saint putin but we're
trying to make this work
and we want to figure out a way
to compromise this is not fair we're
losing you know people are dying
innocent kids are being you know you
don't want that on your you know hands
that that's on you nope that argument is
done but putin's not going to sit down
with you negotiate today because and if
he does everything you say he doesn't
believe anything that comes out of your
mouth am i wrong
i i think you might be wrong okay okay i
hope because we haven't tried to explore
that uh you know uh before russia
invaded ukraine and i won't quibble over
whether it's a proxy war or not i mean i
i i think one can argue that it is a
proxy war in the sense that russian and
u.s troops are not directly engaged with
each other and that's what i mean when
i'm talking about a proxy war that's a
good thing and that's what most people
yeah that's a that's a good thing uh you
know uh but i i i i also agree with you
that certainly from the russian
perspective and uh from the nato
perspective in terms of what we're
saying publicly and all the rest our
objective does seem to be
uh you know uh to try to achieve regime
change in russia through ukraine i mean
senator lindsey graham for example you
know has called uh
you know for uh providing no exit for
russia out of this and that we're gonna
stay in this thing to the end and there
are some analysts expecting
extraordinary results uh you know from
this that for example the putin could
fall from power that we could force the
russians to give up all their tactical
nuclear weapons uh that russia will have
to return all of the conquered
territories
from ukraine which i think is
unrealistic and extremely dangerous to
expect those outcomes and this from
people who before the invasion happened
was expecting russia to run over ukraine
in 72 hours you know when your
intelligence is so wrong you know that
ought to give you pause about whether
you should be involved in the war when
your intelligence is so wrong
and i you know because i i know i i
think it's wrong again having these very
unrealistic expectations but um
the russians offered a peace treaty a
six-point peace treaty before they
invaded ukraine
and uh i i have argued uh
i think
i think we could uh
win the new cold war in ukraine by
negotiating a peace with russia
offering to negotiate peace with are we
doing that they no we're not why are we
not doing that
because the uh
uh
the biden administration
claims they did but they didn't
seriously try to negotiate that piece
okay
uh you know
uh yeah i think that because the uh the
biden administration is uh
uh
listening to people who think that they
can win
uh the new cold war against russia by
defeating
russia
i think they have a very short sight
things are going well right now in
ukraine
and they want to keep pumping arms in
there to make things as bad for the
russians as possible
uh you know and and hope that maybe some
of these really
uh
extraordinary developments that they're
hoping for that might be putin will fall
from power
or at least we'll give russia such a
bloody nose in ukraine that the chinese
will be deterred from trying to invade
taiwan because the same thing will
happen to them and uh and uh and that uh
and that if we can use ukraine the proxy
of ukraine to really inflict a serious
defeat on the russians that it'll
keep the russians pacified and in their
cage you know for years to come
and therefore
this is uh it's worth doing this and
it's worth taking these risks to do that
and we're not really taking risks anyway
because everyone knows a nuclear war
cannot be won and and uh and must never
be fought and so putin's nuclear threats
are not going to be uh are not are not
going to be acted upon and i think that
that's it's a very shallow
uh
uh uh dangerous uh policy that we're
following that assumes that russia will
not resort to nuclear or emp or cyber
warfare on a large scale against nato
europe or against the united states
itself
in order to prevail it's also based on
the premise that
that russia is
really on the ropes in a in
a deeply serious way and that might not
be true we don't know that that is true
at all i mean russia has been fighting
this war with one hand you know with its
left arm and its right arm tied behind
its back you know they've only committed
a really a relatively small fraction of
their forces despite what's being said
in the newspapers and all the rest you
know they have now fully mobilized to
fight fight this war even john bolton
who wants us to do what the biden
administration is doing and wants to
have this war a big war against russia
even john bolton is talking about well
you know we need to be prepared to fight
a war against russia he's calling the 30
to 100 years war
you know because this is uh because
putin and not just putin but he believes
the russian elites that this isn't just
putin's war but that the russian elites
who want to restore the russian empire
that this is a maine
that they consider this essential you
know to their geo long-term geopolitical
survival to reconstitute the old ussr
including taking over ukraine and that
they are going to be willing to fight 30
to 100 years you know
in ukraine in order to achieve that
objective and so we have to be prepared
and i think for example you just take
that one thing are we going to be
prepared to fight russia for 30 to 100
100 years in order to win the ukraine
war how much credibility does john
bolton have today aside from the fact
that you know
anytime he's willing to trash trump you
know the media wants to bring him on but
when you make a comment like this
what does the average person think when
they read this how much credibility do
you give this guy when somebody like him
writes that
putin's 30 or 100 year war for ukraine
like that's what we got to do who's
going to buy into that by the way can
you pull up the new york times article
you know when when he says you know
putin's popularity is increasing you're
thinking well how do we know that
uh go to the one i just texted you i
sense this the one facebook for no go to
is this the one or no
face with pressure uh uh is this the one
yeah look at that one go a little lower
look what his popularity is if you go a
little lower
uh
okay second paragraph eighty-three
percent of russians said they approve of
mr putin's actions up from sixty-nine
percent in january according to a poll
by
lavada center an independent pollster in
moscow ratings of many other government
institutions as well as governing party
have also gone up this is being written
by the most liberal paper
in america to say 83 percent like if
there's anything that would need to
write a propaganda would be the fact
that even the russian people don't agree
with their leader which is putin
so
and it is one of the most pro-biden uh
papers in america as well yeah far far
left i mean supporting anything that's
uh
you know
wall street journal would be in the
middle these maybe center right these
guys are far left
why why are the russian people so
supportive of him
why are the russian people so supportive
of him and at the same time if this
guy's at 83 percent you know biden's
right now 39 percent
why are the russian people so supportive
of them why are so many american people
not supportive biden
well let me go to answer your john
bolton question first i didn't want to
just pass by that well who would take
john bolton seriously
uh you know most people in washington
would the establishment republicans
would uh you know the people who didn't
like a lot of them who didn't like trump
even those who did support trump i
i i have long been a uh
an admirer of john bolton although i
disagree with him on a lot of things
yeah you know uh he he had he does have
a
a keen analytical mind you know uh uh
you know he he has deep due strategic
insights into into matters uh which is
why despite his combative
personality
all right that has uh that often gets
him in trouble in positions that he's
held
held in government that he has been
respected with
held you know high posts like that so
there are a lot of people that would
take and should take john bolton uh
seriously uh now i uh
i am i am more of a trump fan than i am
of a a bolton supporter and i
fundamentally disagree with bolton on a
lot of things i think his uh his
analysis for example his recommendations
his prescription for
ukraine doesn't flow logically from his
own analysis
i mean i find it
impossible to imagine i mean i think
it's a certainty that if we had tried to
engage in a war for ukraine for 30 to
100 years that we would lose you know
nato and the united states don't have
the political will or we don't have
national interests invested in ukraine
that are so serious that we would be
willing to fight with russia for 30 to
100 years to prevail
so but nonetheless that's what he wants
us to do
um uh we didn't have the political will
to impose our our uh
the outcome on afghanistan that we
wanted against the taliban you know who
are not nearly as formidable and
adversary as uh
as the russians are so you know there's
a disconnect here i i often see between
a lot of what
uh you know bolton argues
he would answer me back by saying
in in this article he says we have to
prevail in ukraine
because
because ukraine is poland in 1939
and uh and if we don't prevail you know
there's going to be a world war iii that
this is going to have
in fact he does say this in the article
that the reverberations of any kind of a
russian victory in ukraine are going to
be so profound that china and north
korea and iran and russia itself will be
encouraged to continue aggression and
we're going to find ourselves in world
war iii so this is our polish 1939
moment
we've got to step up we've got to stop
him for achieving victory and i say to
that this is not the time and place we
can win
if you don't want that a world war iii
don't go into some situation we're
almost guaranteed to lose
you know we're guaranteed to lose at a
conventional level because we can't
fight a 30 to 100 years war and russia
is not going to fight for a third 100
years they're going to use emp cyber
nuclear
you know to quickly win the war and
we're not prepared for any of that you
know we need time to rebuild to really
build
and modernize our nuclear deterrent we
need time to build our general purpose
forces so that we can prevail in a world
war iii if that becomes necessary and we
most especially need time to find
competent political and military
leadership can you imagine joe biden and
general miley leading us into a world
war iii we're going to lose just based
on the leadership the terrible
leadership we we have now we we nee we
need competent political military
leadership so that we can
so that we can prevail who who wants who
what what uh uh
who wants america to get weaker outside
of forget about the enemies what i'm
talking about is you the name that comes
up often is what what are your thoughts
about uh world economic forum you know
in the world health organizations and
these organizations that kind of stand
alone and yeah they're here for the
world and you know you'll hear the name
coming up with claus schwab and you know
where he's at and what he's trying to do
and you know the new world order where
do you stand with that when you hear
that
well the left and the globalists want
america to get weaker
uh you know
that's been a divide i think that wasn't
really appreciated until trump came
along okay
uh you know with his america first
policy which is anathema to
establishment
washington
that's because these people aren't
nationalists they're globalists
they want to use american power they
want to use america as an engine to
realize a a a a a globalist
uh world order you know that's dominated
by supranational institutions like the
united nations and the world courts and
world economic forums and the elites who
run these things will be making the
decisions for us
you know and uh uh whenever they
try to encourage us and and
most of the wars that we've been
fighting in recent decades
have this globalist agenda you know uh
the war in ukraine the reason we're
there is because
we want uh
we want people to think we want the
nations to think that warfare is
obsolete that in the 21st century you
can't
uh fight wars and you shouldn't be
acting on national interests the way
russia is okay uh that you that you need
to subordinate your concept of national
interests to this larger
agenda the globalists believe
uh and the left that nationalism is evil
you know that it is responsible for the
wars of the past and the way of getting
into a peaceful
ordered world uh is by subordinate
subordinating nationalism and
maybe evolving past it altogether the
concept of the world citizen
that's why
our borders are wide open okay this uh
because that implies
a nationalism that implies you know
old-fashioned nation states they want
open borders uh they want supernational
institutions running everything
and uh a lot of the wars that don't make
sense to most americans because most
americans are nationalists and our
america first
r r and they say why are we in
afghanistan why are we in iraq uh the
rationalization there are
rationalizations that are concocted
uh to appeal to them and say well we're
in afghanistan because of the war on
terrorism because we don't want the bad
guys to come and attack the united
states again from afghanistan and that
was the rationalization there
and the rationalization for going into
ukraine
our involvement in ukraine is well we
don't want russia and china uh you know
to attack our allies and uh and u.s
interests in world war iii and and that
makes sense
to a lot of americans it makes enough
sense so that we've been willing to
support wars like that okay but is that
the real reason the elites are going
into these wars
uh no that's not the real reason you
know the real reason is uh is uh
uh is these globalist explanations the
idea that uh
you know that any nation that violates
another nation's sovereignty has to be
punished and therefore america is going
to be the world policeman on behalf of
these supranational institutions
enforcing you know this new globalist
world order
and that's why
that's why the biden administration
uh
uh and uh and and the european union and
the nato alliance that's why they're in
ukraine it's because of the uh uh of
these uh so we have elites who use
nationalist rationalizations to convince
the people to try to
convince the people yeah we need to stay
and keep staying in afghanistan forever
and forever
uh but you can also see a lot of the
agenda there for example in afghanistan
i mean how was it serving our interests
to
to want to turn afghanistan not not only
to quell the taliban okay but we were we
were trying to turn them into a feminist
secular democracy
okay and have the values of the
globalists imposed on a country like
afghanistan which is clearly an
impossible
uh thing to do and uh you know uh you
know afghanistan is
you know it never went through the
enlightenment it never went through the
renaissance it didn't have an industrial
none of the historical things happened
to make it that happened in western
europe to make possible a democratic
secular feminist democracy you know and
yet uh you know the nation building you
know the notion of nation building
itself is really globalist nation
building you know building the nation uh
with value systems uh uh that uh that
are embraced by the globalists uh so
you've got a this is the dilemma and i
think
americans are waking up to it
that their leaders
despite what they say to them about
their agenda you know in these countries
where they appeal to our patriotism to
get involved in a war that really they
have ulterior motives that have to do
with uh globalist interests that are not
the same and oftentimes are opposed to
what u.s vital national interests are
and and i think ukraine is a great
example of that you know the vital
national interest of national interest
of the united states right now is to not
get in a nuclear war with russia that
could destroy the united states that's
more important than anything but our
policy is acting like that doesn't
matter at all and that we can just keep
doing and pushing and and uh
and why you know and that's because
american national interests are not
first and foremost in ukraine it's the
globalist agenda you know russia's got
to be punished for trying to protect its
national interests what it perceives is
its national interests and its empire
building in ukraine and uh and they've
got to be brought to heal
and uh and and uh and what is the
solution though to just stay out of the
way and let them uh
is a solution let them do whatever they
want to do with ukraine and we do
nothing is that the solution
well in the end we may not be able to
have any control but
my solution you know what i think we
should do
you know uh biden i think should uh
should mobilize u.s nuclear forces and
put them at least on defcon 3 right even
though putin put his nuclear forces on
alert back on february 27th okay
you know
historically whenever the russians have
done that
we
increase we mobilize our forces so that
there are more survivable posture you
know we have no choice we're supposed to
do that because we don't want them to be
able to do nuclear pearl harbor on us
but the bike administration has broken
precedent and has left our forces at
defcon 5 which is the lowest readiness
level and they're saying well we don't
see any evidence that the russians have
really mobilized their forces which is a
lie because there's actually all kinds
of evidence that putin
has mobilized those forces and uh and
those forces actually don't even have to
be all that mobilized because the
russian strategic forces are designed to
make a surprise attack
24 7 all the time they're on a condition
called constant combat readiness
and uh and so when conditions exist
where russia hasn't
may have a reason to launch a surprise
nuclear attack we need to mobilize our
forces to survivable posture so one of
the first things i did would do is i
would mobilize those forces go at least
the defcon 3
so that it would make it harder for them
to do a nuclear pearl harbor you know
we're offering there next to them right
now and then i would immediately inform
putin and say
we're mobilizing our forces you've left
us no choice we've got to do it because
you mobilized your forces and we've
exercised great patience you know we've
been waiting for you to come down with
uh with your forces but you haven't so
uh we're not planning to attack you but
you've left us no choice okay
and uh neither of us wants to have a
nuclear world war uh you know so
let's try to eliminate the problem and
negotiate a peace in ukraine right now
uh and we and and i'm willing to
negotiate with you on the basis of the
uh peace treaty that you had offered to
the united states and nato europe before
you invaded ukraine let's go back and
we'll negotiate i'm not going to say
that we're going to give you all
your points but there are many points in
that peace treaty that are just as much
in our interests as they are in nato's
interests excuse me in russia's
interests uh for example you know
not bringing ukraine into nato you know
uh you know yes we're gonna we're gonna
give you that we're not gonna expand
nato further eastward so all these
partnership for peace countries that
kazakhstan tajikistan kurdistan south
easter you know uh uh all these uh
countries that are in on on the way to
becoming nato members you know because
they're in a partnership for peace we'll
we're going to give we're going to give
you that those are examples of
of things that i would readily agree to
in the treaty so there's a lot that
could be
could be given up
and uh uh
and uh
i would try to use the negotiations
beyond achieving peace in ukraine
uh i would try to use the negotiations
uh to hit the reset button with the
relations with russia you know because
uh our real objective should be to split
the russian chinese alliance you know we
face the most formidable block of
military and economic power that we've
ever faced in our history this new axis
that comprises not just russia and china
united but north korea and iran too
they're all part of this
anti-western bloc
and i don't think we can win a new cold
war or a world war iii against that
block of power
they have not only do they have the
economic and military advantages but
they have the advantage of political
will these are the totalitarian and
authoritarian states they're they've
been willing to sacrifice millions of
their own people building socialism they
would be willing to sacrifice far many
more people than we would to win a world
war iii against us we don't want to get
into that situation so we need to
we need to we need to split that russian
chinese alliance
as a way of pulling the whole world back
from the edge of a war and turn it into
a new cold war a competition that's
economic and diplomatic and political
not a military confrontation and so i
would use the negotiations over ukraine
to try to hit the reset button with
russia and make them at least neutral
okay in the new cold war with china or
even a strategic partner because i think
putin
i think putin was willing to do that
during the trump administration you know
i think putin knows that in the long run
china is a bigger threat to russia than
the west and that he's better he knows
that i think he knows that i think it's
obvious you know when you when you look
at
world what's up exactly
well what's obvious is that russia has a
shared border with china as a
diminishing population and a diminishing
economy china is greedy for the natural
resources including in siberia and and
territory i think putin knows that the
russians are chess players you know that
after world war three suppose there is a
world war three and that defeat us okay
there's going to be a world war iv and
that's going to be between
the new access
you know russia and china will confront
each other in that world war iv and i
don't think putin wants that i think
he'd rather
he'd rather be a strategic partner with
the west and avoid both a world war iii
and a world war iv if possible
if he could hit that reset button and
have us as a partner to protect russia
against china and i think putin all
through the trump administration was
waiting for trump to hit the reset
button that was their plan that was what
general flynn was advising before he got
you know got fired over over that
nonsense and uh uh
you know but trump was not ever in a
position politically where he could make
it happen the democrat party you know
made it impossible for president trump
to do this
to take this step that was vital to our
national security to try to hit the
reset button with russia you know
they're accusing of being putin's puppet
and uh and and and and uh and uh uh and
it wasn't politically possible for him
to do it
that uh but we could do it if we were
now if we were negotiating over ukraine
uh
uh
you know
we try to protect ukrainian interests
you know as much as as much as we could
it helps that that the ukraine
apparently has been prevailing a lot of
these areas you know i don't think that
we're going to be able to get uh you
know the don bass back any areas that
the russians actually control you know
ukraine might have to resign itself to
becoming a rump state and in the long
run you know you cr it may not be
possible to save ukraine at all you know
because russia is going to consider it a
vital geostrategic interest of its but
at least temporarily you know uh uh you
know in uh uh
at least temporarily uh because ukraine
has had good fortune in the war
you know uh we would have been able to
buy some time for ukraine but my
concern is not ukraine you know america
has no vital interest in ukraine except
avoiding the nuclear war with russia and
gaining and and if we can turn lemons
into lemonade and gain a strategic
partnership with russia
our vital interest is avoiding nuclear
war with russia
and getting them to be a neutral or a
strategic partner in the new cold war
with china so that we can prevail in the
new cold war with china or world war iii
if that becomes necessary
and that's uh that's what i would do and
i think people would be surprised that
despite all of the the rhetoric and all
the rest all the angst over over the
ukraine war
i think uh we might be pleasantly
surprised at how quickly you know russia
is willing to and they maybe might even
be willing to make temporary very
significant concessions over ukraine in
order to have that strategic partnership
with the west so that they're not in a
a doomed partnership with china a
partnership with china that's ultimately
going to doom russia even if they win
world war iii because they won't
probably win world war iv against china
and by the way that's why china is
rapidly building up its nuclear forces
you know right now china needs russia
because russia is the dominant nuclear
power in the world by far
but china is building up nuclear
capabilities so that
by or before 2030
they will be a nuclear challenge to
russia those nuclear weapons i think are
aimed they are aimed at us but i think
china is thinking about world war 4 too
is russia helping china build nuclear
weapons or give them any supplies they
have been the the the
the whole and this is one of the thing
reasons i think we'd be able to do a
deal with putin because i think he's
russia
not just putin
they're probably disappointed in uh in
in
and what they've gotten back from china
because uh china went from
pretty much a militarily backward
country you know that we weren't all
that concerned about uh but in a couple
of decades they've been built into a
pure competitor with the united states
both with conventional forces
modern navy modern army modern air force
and now they've got uh you know modern
nuclear weapon systems and all of this
has been built
on technology that's been stolen from
the united states but also technology
that they've gotten from russia in fact
some of the most important stuff is
russian supply technology for both
conventional and nuclear forces a great
example is that is the new icbm the
df-41 icbm
which is uh you know a mirved icbm it'll
carry 10 war it looks a lot like
russia's ss18 in terms of it being a
mirved warhead it's a first strike
weapon highly accurate but unlike the
ss18 it's mobile it's actually a mobile
missile which makes it even better for a
surprise attack and that's all built on
russian technology
and uh uh the russians have got some
things back from the strategic
partnership but
uh the relationship has been
disproportionately beneficial to china
you know the chinese have been cheap
partners you know they have uh
what what
russia has built them into a world-class
competitor that could
arguably win world war iii against the
united states and russia has you know
the economic benefits they've gotten
from that relationship are are
you know not nearly as impressive as i i
think as the russians would like and
they know that these capabilities will
eventually be turned against themselves
pbd how are you processing i mean let me
just recap what he just said and
maybe i got
you just went from
world war three potentially russia with
china as an ally
taking out the united states the west
and then somehow got right from there to
already world war iv
russia versus china the remnants of who
wins that
i got that part and then
initially before that we talked about
globalism and pat initiated the entire
conversation with what's changed since
three weeks ago well the world economic
forum was just held in davos switzerland
uh if there's anything that that i took
from that is that the eu
is getting closer and stronger they used
to be called the the russian house in
davos they changed the name to the
russian war crimes house located in
davos i don't know if we have that
picture
but it seems like eu is getting stronger
um
at the united states obviously proxy war
with eu ukraine
world war three boom world war four is
already happening there's the russian
war crimes house
i'm just kind of processing all that how
are you
what's your biggest takeaway so far we
spent almost four hours
you said something last time on last
time's uh podcast with uh
uh dr pry is you said you know the
difference between america and some of
these countries is we don't have to
worry about who's on our border we don't
mexico and what is it canada what do we
got to worry about by the way did you
hear about canada story yesterday what
justin trudeau just announced the
difference is
imagine if us
was border to china
and china keeps getting stronger and
stronger and stronger
what do you think world war four is
going to be probably u.s china so i i
what he's saying is not that out of uh
but he's saying world war four would be
russia china i know i agree but i tell
you what i'm more concerned about is
is if u.s if if you world war 4
is
china and russia against everybody
that's what you really got to worry
about i'm it's totally it's a much
better situation if world war 4 is china
against russia
you don't want world war iv to be china
and russia against
everybody else you don't want that you
want those two guys to
if they're gonna if there's gonna be a
war that that's better to be them to
than anybody else them uniting against
everybody else but what are we worried
about mexico i mean what's going on with
mexico who are you worried about
colombia what were you worried about
argentina brazil canada you think justin
trudeau
you know with his aggressive stand he
took yesterday to freeze gun sales we
are capping the number of handguns in
this country
right and what he announced i don't know
if you saw what he know did you watch
the video yesterday what he announced
the fact that
he stood up there with 20 men standing
behind him with masks on
uh extremely responsible people and
you know what we're going to do is take
guns away from people like
the the angle he's taken do you worry
about him attacking you no no what he's
doing is and america sits there and says
okay you guys just got weaker but let me
bring it to you on what you're asking
with trudeau
obviously i'm sure you're following the
san antonio story very closely
i'm sure you have been following the
story closely what happened with
uh uh i want to say salvador ramos right
am i saying the last time correctly
ramos right
and video came out the other day with
cops are waiting to go in we don't have
the right tools and that's led into all
this conversation about gun reform and
you know this one could have been saved
people from both sides have come out and
said this could have been prevented from
happening
there was many mistakes that was made
from the you know
stand you know don't don't go in yet how
are you handling the conversations
that's being had right now about having
gun reform and if we could have any kind
of reform i'm curious do you like the
way we have it today or any ideas you
would have
that you would suggest any kind of
reforms from your end
well naturally the left and the forces
of pro-government that want to diminish
our freedoms are focusing on the guns
okay
and uh and i think that's completely uh
misplaced
uh you know the uh
uh i don't think gun reform
uh uh
would have prevented
any of the measures
even if they confiscated guns from all
law-abiding americans
this person would have come up with some
kind of a weapon you know to kill
children
you know
and and maybe uh kill even more people
whether it's an explosives or uh
uh
uh
uh you know or
you know black market firearms or a
machete
uh
you know i think the uh
the focus needs to be more on mental
health
uh
uh
uh tucker carlson had a good uh
he he ran a tape from charles
krautheimer who had been a psychiatrist
a very respected television commentator
but he originally had been a a you know
a medical psychiatrist and that's how he
had made his living and he made the
point
that
uh you know the problem
is the way government is handling people
who obviously have mental problems
uh you know they're not
institutionalizing them they're not
uh they're not bringing them in uh to uh
when somebody makes a threat as this
person did before they killed people
that ought to trigger bring in a person
you know people should report that to
the police and the police should then
take this person have them mentally
evaluated and if this person is judged
by competent psychiatrists to be a
threat they should be kept
institutionalized
and the uh the proclivity of of of the
medical bureaucracy to just release
dangerous people has got to be reversed
as well you know uh the the bias should
be uh that uh you know unless you are
yourself willing to maybe
uh
accept legal consequences for letting go
somebody who later kills people
uh you know uh so that so that you're
not scot-free if you're a psychiatrist
and you say okay uh i'm i'm letting this
person out on the streets and then you
have you're not at legal risk at all
yourself
uh you know that's just encouraging
emptying out the psychiatric hospitals
uh you know that's the direction that we
need to be able to take the the left
wants to protect the privacy rights of
these people
more than the lives of children
you know and they would prefer to blame
the boogeyman of guns when the real
boogie man is these the small very small
percentage of of mentally ill and evil
people you know uh who are being
protected by the left basically through
privacy laws and by
high-end tying the hands of both the
police and psychiatric institutions and
putting allowing so many people of these
people
that we don't keep
institutionalized anymore because it
costs money you know and it's cheaper to
let them go off and become homeless and
become dangers to uh to society you know
it's it's the policies of the left and
you know conservatives are always
fighting on the defensive being put on
the back foot by saying uh you know over
the gun rights argument when the real
argument should be
uh you know over
a mental health policy and how do we
treat you know this this this portion of
the population
also i think uh
uh
you know uh you we ought to be more
aggressive in protecting our children
uh you know
uh
uh you know there ought to be in every
elementary school and public school you
know an officer maybe a retired cop uh
you know uh
uh
you know armed uh or the principal
should be armed or a parent uh you know
uh who's trained in the use of firearms
ought to be uh uh vigilantly protecting
these schools where their own children
are located uh you know
on a on a volunteer basis uh we also
need to think about
more seriously about uh about just the
architectural security of these uh of of
these schools uh you know
uh
so many windows you know that uh and and
multiple entrances that people can get
that people can get into
uh you know the schools ought to be
designed with safety doors for example
once that door is secured you know you'd
need a you know
you need should need hours to get
through it you shouldn't be able to just
walk in
uh so there are a lot of practical
things we can do are you for background
checks or no uh background checks
certainly yeah okay you afford them
getting rid of uh
um
uh the uh what do you call it uh
yesterday i posted this on twitter if
you can go to my twitter account i just
kind of want to share with this
uh last night i i'm really zooming a
little bit more so we can see it yeah go
a little lower so justin trudeau's video
keep going keep going keep going keep
going so he says this message here
and i tweeted it out and i said why just
guns nearly 1900 fatalities last year
from car accidents in canada while 277
fatalities from guns in the same year
since you're so concerned about the
lives of people let's get real tough and
ban all cars right because that's seven
times the amount of people that died
from cars than they did with guns sure
so so the solution isn't to just say
well you know
let's ban all guns okay fine so his
proposal uh that he proposed is limits
on size of magazines i think it's five
rounds nobody should have more than five
rounds harsher criminal penalties for
trafficking guns fine a red flag gun gun
law stripping firearm licenses from
people involved in domestic violence
okay that's kind of what he wants to do
then if you go above it and i kind of
want to run this by you as well go a
little higher so i asked a question i
post post a video that we had with
catalina laugh if you remember when we
talked about what happened in santa toni
go a little higher go a little higher go
a little higher that one right there
click on that one so i said okay so if
if cause both sides they're so emotional
you you're not gonna take away my guns
you know you're going to have to go
through my
m16 if you want to take my gun you can
and we how can you be so this and you
know and there's no way do you not
understand lives were lost so i said
okay perfect how would you improve or
reform our current gun laws in u.s
comment belong like the ones you you
like the most so i want to kind of read
you what some of the people on twitter
said yesterday just kind of get your
feet so first one says
get to get the mentally ill people the
help they need kind of like what you
just talked about
make constitutional carry the law in all
50 states you can tell where that guy
leans
repeal the nfa i think you want to say
nra but maybe saying the nfa repeal atf
okay go show more replies so we can see
it
give everyone bb guns he's trying to be
funny educating our society first fine
mandatory safety training
takes a few hours provides a certificate
and send them home with a locking case
for the firearm doesn't seem
unreasonable to train people who are
buying guns
psych meds equals no firearms i kind of
agree with that one keep going lower uh
gta 5 kill go okay without morality
let's see what the next first and
foremost i would prohibit big pharma to
market directly to consumer that's a
complete different conversation right
mental health is the issue not guns goes
back to what you're saying mental health
or not so much the problem is the ease
of accessibility to buy guns because
people with mental health will always be
there so let's find a way to stop these
people from acting on their evil
thoughts okay
six month wait list that's a long time
background checks and national register
this kid planned this for two years how
does that change or stop anything good
argument counter argument to him i would
say let's revoke every unconstitutional
law in 50 states dc and territories
let as many people as one to any place
in america conceal carry murders and
murderers and criminals would soon
change their bad habits what do you
think about that that's an interesting
take i don't think we have a gun law
issue i think we have a law enforcement
enforcement issue
any form of gun control is
unconstitutional abolish all forms of
gun laws anyways this keeps going on
somebody said 25 years old same age as
renting a car then the argument back is
well if an 18 year old can go to war why
should an 18 euro be able to carry a gun
well then are we more comfortable with
an 18 year old carrying a gun uh rather
than carrying a beer because alcohol is
21 years old in many states right so the
part here is
both sides seems to be seem to be
screaming off the top of their lungs on
what they want no one is really willing
to sit down and have a conversation
about it which argument have you seen
from the
side that is not the conservative side
that you've said i think they do have
some kind of a point should we increase
the age should we do a little bit more
training before somebody can just buy a
gun or leave the place
what should we do to improve uh some of
the issues when surrounding guns i agree
with the idea that if you're getting
psycho psycho
drug treatment for
psychological problems uh you know that
that should be
uh
automatically prohibitive in terms of
gun ownership
i agree with uh you know people who are
respond guilty of domestic violence you
know uh you know that that uh that that
uh uh that should restrict you know
firearms ownership
and i'm answering your question because
you asked me
what solutions have come from the left
okay that i would agree with but most
solutions from the left i don't agree
with
my bias is always to give more freedom
to people not less
i said earlier that i do believe in
background checks i do provide and
they're not abused by government and you
always have to suspect government
because the inclination in government
like for example in washington dc where
they abuse background checks in new york
city to the point where they are
basically rescinding people's second
amendment rights and that's not right uh
you know government has proven itself uh
so
greedy of power
uh uh you know and
and most americans the population that
is all for gun control and all the rest
they don't understand
uh or maybe they just don't care
uh you know that the second amendment is
there for a reason it's not for
recreation it's not for sports and
hunting it's because in the federalist
papers when we were convinced when the
colonies were convinced to form a
federal government with the government
in washington
that we needed an armed citizenry to be
the last bastion of defense against
tyranny you know the
the
constitution and the second amendment
that's in there was written by a
revolutionary generation the first
battle of the american revolution was a
question of over over firearms you know
the british were going
to lexington and concord to confiscate
the malicious guns and gunpowder and
disarm the citizenry so they could be
oppressed and the founders knew that so
this business is about second amendment
rights you know being for hunting
rights and recreational that's not why
we have a second amendment it's because
the people
and we know this not just in our own
american revolution
but you know in every
tyranny that has arisen in history
they try to disarm the people and make
them sheep so that they are powerless
against the government so we need to be
extremely protective of the of the power
i think people i think the gun laws are
too restrictive in terms of the types of
firearms not only should this business
about limiting magazines no you know
are i think you can make a a good
practical and constitutional case uh
that americans should be allowed to own
firearms that are equivalent to
military-grade firearms because really
yeah because of that role
now do you think america needs more guns
or less guns
i think it needs more good guns you know
what does that mean i think it needs
more guns so that if it became necessary
to have a second american revolution the
average american would stand a chance
you know the average sporting rifle or
or shotgun
take it do a test sometime and take it
out to a firing range and see how many
rounds you can put through it before it
starts jamming up you'll find that a a
sporting rifle
you know actually
uh can't do sustained fire for very long
but you're saying that americans need
more militaristic type weapons in
average american hands
yeah what reason
to fight against government because i'm
increasingly fearful that we're heading
toward a tyranny and uh and that there's
and the reason the government wants to
confiscate guns and restrict gun
ownership is because they want to they
want to have a tyranny over us you know
there's a faction that says we already
have way too many guns here in the
united states i mean i think we have
tyler i think i sent you some of these
stats we have four percent of the
world's population
what percentage of the world's guns do
you think we have
i don't know i don't take a guess
you know
fifty percent that's a that's exactly
right we have four percent of the
world's population
we have fifty percent of the world's
firearms you say that we should have
more and more um do your militaristic
type guns and switzerland i don't know
i'm just stating facts i'm not like i'm
just giving yeah
i am saying that i'm saying there's i
see no reason
in a constitutional republic where the
people are supposed to be in charge okay
and that we don't belong to the
government we're not the property of the
government we're supposed to be free
independent people
that we need to have the ability to
protect our liberties and protect
ourselves from our own government which
has become increasing increasingly
intrusive and oppressive uh you know uh
and uh
uh
and and and and the trend to the trend
line uh is is going away from being a
constitutional republic toward becoming
a tyranny i don't think we're actually a
constitutional republic anymore i think
we're currently a tyranny but we're in
the soft faces of tyranny but isn't the
biggest problem right now protecting
innocent kids not so much the government
trying to come after you well that's
that's certainly the the biggest
immediate problem because we've had this
issue but i think
thinking people have to take a longer
view
and uh and and it's in addition to
protecting our children and our children
by the way i think have to be protected
from our government too
you know i am extremely
of course it's tragic that though those
children were killed by that person by
that mentally deranged person but it
wasn't
it wasn't the gun that killed those
people it was the public policy the
government has followed that has put
lunatics like that out in the street and
government has changed the policies so
that so that our our situation is more
dangerous
i'm very concerned about uh a government
uh you know that thinks that child abuse
institutionalized child abuse is okay
and that's what we've got when you're
teaching kindergartners through third
graders for example about transsexuality
and having conversation and expecting
teachers to educate our children on
matters that
when i was growing up if a stranger in a
park came up to you and started talking
to you about the things that we have our
encourage our elementary school teachers
to talk to our children about that
person would be arrested as a child
predator you know but we have government
sanctioning that and doing that to our
children you know i'm not really that
pervasive of a problem i get that
there's some teachers that do that but
is that
is that sort of a straw man approach
that all these nobody's not going to be
sir sir it is not a straw man it's being
done all across the country parents all
across the country are up in arms and
being arrested in school board meetings
for trying to protect their children
from child abuse you know by the way if
i may
there is
way more of that happening
than
uh yes the gun
issues that we're having just so you
know there is not even 10 times more
there's way more what issues there's way
more of the teachers trying to influence
kids way of thinking with what he's
talking about with transgenderism
there's a hundred times more of that
happening than the issue with guns but
the government's not putting their
attention there the government's going
straight to guns
let's address guns let's not think about
the long-term ramifications of shifting
the way kids think we're not thinking
about that we're thinking about the
finite war not the infinite war there's
a big difference between a finite war
and an infinite war so i agree with that
part there on
uh what he's saying where you're going
with this
in regards to guns can you put up that
one thing you put up by the way you said
four percent of 50 somebody could say
you know we are four percent of the
world's population but we are 20 the
wealth okay then what do you say about
that right you know so so we're much
we're that much freer than the rest of
the world because we unlike the rest of
the world
you know own guns so the fact that we
own fifty percent of the world's guns if
that's true i don't know that it is but
let me point out some other things
that's left go ahead all right in
switzerland you know every adult male
you know who is part of the swiss
militia who can surf in the military is
required to have an automatic
military-grade uh
uh weapon an assault rifle a real
assault rifle in their house uh you know
with hundreds of rounds of ammunition so
that if they're called up that's
switzerland which has some of the lowest
uh gun crime so-called gun crime
they phrase it in the world in the 19th
century before we had the kind of modern
gun wall laws that we have now where
carrying firearms was very commonplace
among people
you know we
the crime the murder rates and the rest
were much lower than they are today
you know this does it isn't the guns
that are causing the crime uh you know
it's the it's the culture that's causing
the crime and uh you know and i think
that a lot of this is correlated with uh
uh
the destruction of our culture because
of big government in the role that it
plays which is increasingly which is
increasingly destructive yes we need to
be armed to protect ourselves from an
increasingly predatory government
you know that is uh that is frankly not
a constitutional republic as i said
before and why did i say that
that's because in order to have a
constitutional republic you need to at
least two political parties both
political parties everybody has to obey
the law and respect the constitution
we i think we cease to be a
constitutional republic at least from
the first year of the trump
administration with the democrat party
engaged in
uh
unconstitutional and illegal behavior by
bringing false charges against president
trump that he was a russian agent and
that he needed to be invest they knew
that was a lie they abused the law they
abused the constitution to undermine a
political opponent
and uh and i think the 2020 elections
were also stolen you know by the
democrat party i think people anybody
who hasn't watched 2 000 mules should
watch it but i think you don't even have
to watch that just common sense would
tell you that a guy like biden
who has how i don't know how many times
he ran for president three four times
and he never got more than two percent
of the vote now we're expected to
believe that he got more votes than any
president in american history the 2020
elections were stolen so many will tell
you that that's because they trump was
hated that much more people voting
against him
than voting for him
yeah well that's what they that's what
they say but watch two thousand mules
and see what happened we had dinner on
before but so yeah so okay this this
article right switzerland has won the
highest rates of gun ownership in the
world but little gun related street
crime so opponents uh some opponents of
gun control hail it as a place where
firearms play a positive role in society
however swiss gun
uh culture is unique and guns are more
tightly regulated than many assume okay
for me the one part where
the right has to
use a little bit of
um
i don't know how to from from my
standpoint
there is nothing wrong with requiring a
little bit of training
there's nothing wrong with giving me a
one-day training
two-day training where i got to get a
sign-off where i got to go to something
where i gotta go shoot or have somebody
that's teaching me the basics a former
vet or former military i don't know i
think just sitting around and saying
yeah it's it's not a big deal it's not
this is i i would much rather have a
hundred percent of people that are on
non-meds non-domestic violence
non-mental issues a hundred percent of
adults
have a gun or a weapon that they are
trained to use
then have fifty percent of america that
are able to buy guns
and they have no experience to have any
kind of weapons you know training or how
to use it i'd much rather drive training
my idea is to drive training drive
education drive being in a community to
say do this be careful with this when
you're making a left turn with a car
look at this mirror 10-2 basic stuff
that we learned at 16 years old those 10
20 basic things to teach somebody with
guns that you can also tell them you
know certain things i i think there are
some things we can do to improve in that
area anyways we ran out of time this was
this has been a great podcast uh dr
price thank you for coming back folks
for some of you guys that are
with us i'm hosting a webinar tonight
about the market crash i think i don't
know 20 000 people have registered for
to be a part of it it'll be at 5 30.
we're going to talk about a lot of
different stats and history of what's
happening how to prepare for it if you
haven't you register for it's a free
webinar to tyler if you can put the link
below for people to be a part of it
looking forward to seeing many of you
guys there who do we have uh uh this
week is is this the only podcast we're
doing this week over thursday with uh dr
ben carson oh dr ben carson's your
disturbance it's not this thursday dude
i don't think that's i thought that's
the twitter with tim ballard okay tim
ballard is his thursday tyler tim
ballard is this thursday that's a
complete different conversation if
you've seen the nick mckinley podcast
that we've done in the past before this
will be a follow with that dr pry once
again thank you so much for coming out
here and speaking with us and i know the
audience loved it if you like having dr
pryon you want to see him come back
again give us a sup and uh give us a
thumbs up to uh having dr pryon today
but appreciate you for coming out truly
this was great as usual well thank you
so much for having me appreciate it
thank you thank you everybody bye bye
bye
you